was white yeah clarence king not to be
confused with sean king
who by the way when we get to the story
i believe that sean king
sean jeffrey king stole clarence king's
story and that's why he named himself
sean king clarence king he named him
after sean
uh claire sean king named himself after
clarence king because king is not his
family last name
why not i mean it is it's his real dad
was
well i don't know if it's his real dad
probably the dad on his birth
certificate
is a white man named jeffrey king
allegedly no no he that's what's on his
birth certificate who knows
because he [ __ ] also said that he was
a victim of a hate crime and there's no
record of that
yeah there's no record of the hate crime
absolutely zero there
the police report there is a police
report of an incident but that police
report
lists him as white yeah he says it was a
fight between two students
yeah actually sean king should at some
point be brought up on federal charges
for inciting
race stuff and he actually he actually
is like a real like devilish criminal
sean sean king because rachel dolezal
and clarence king it was kind of
they didn't really mean to hurt anybody
they were just doing it we'll get into
the story of clarence king they were
just doing it for love and
but sean king is actually exploiting
people and causing
harm so i i want to see a world where
sean king gets brought up on charges
it's interesting too because
sean king has that story of um a hate
crime where he said
uh you know he missed a year of school
he had multiple back surgeries there's
no
record of any of that none of that
school so it's lying or the hospital and
interestingly enough
rachel dolezal well he says he had that
hate crime happen to him
and that's when he chose blackness after
that because all right
that that made me black or whatever uh
which is an interesting story rachel
dolezal
also made up she's she was sending
letters to herself
right like jessie smolette did yeah
jesse smilet was sending those hate
crime letters to himself
to himself rachel doleza did the same
thing in the p.o box which she only had
the key of
uh but the letters would go into there
or whatever
that she was sending hate crime letters
to herself yeah it's ridiculous and she
like burned across on her own lawn or
whatever
so but because do you think you ever
think about
like a lot of this is just like
entitlement meaning like
the you know people feel entitled for
like a lot of reasons it's like you have
to
because we live in such a world where
there's so
opposite end to the spectrum either you
need to be a [ __ ] superstar and feel
entitled that way or you need to be a
victim and feel entitled that way so i
feel like if you you can't live in the
middle anymore and just be an average
person it's like
average in especially american society
is just not good
so these people that feel insanely
average like a sean king like a rachel
dolezal
like a jessica crew who will talk about
all three of them and maybe even like in
a way clarence king
although we'll get into the clarence
king story he did it for love but these
people
because they can't feel just average and
mediocre
they have to pick an extreme and say i'm
now going to be a victim
of race stuff as like a sense of
entitlement of to say
i deserve something too because i can't
just be mediocre you ever think of that
i do think of that i think it's tied to
the american dream i think it's tied to
what
america markets right like you got to
make something except you got to be some
we we look down on on the middle class
on average people in like other
countries
people feel okay with having a job
everyone here feels like they have to be
a rapper a celebrity
or something it's just like those lives
aren't great but it's marketed like you
have to be
famous even extremely rich and wealthy
and famous people
most of their day is average yes so no
matter what
no matter which way you escape try to
slice it whether you're
a a victim you want to play the victim
in the race card and i'm a victimized by
everything
and you're on tv for a minute being like
i'm a victim most of your day other than
the
little part you're on tv you're average
same thing as [ __ ] drake
most of his day besides when he posts or
does the concert msg
leading up to that it's pretty average
he just wakes up in a hotel or his house
has breakfast like everybody else
brushes his teeth does some other
[ __ ] and then
for two hours in the day one whatever he
does a big concert
but most of drake's time is just average
so
everything even if you get to the
pinnacle lebron james right now
yeah yeah he has a playoff game tonight
and he has practice before it but the
rest of it is just average [ __ ]
sitting around thinking of [ __ ] to do
until he's got time for the practice of
the game
so we're all average there's no question
lebron james wakes up
right he jerks off maybe he jerks off
like a regular like 100
he'll be like you know let me just rub
one out yeah looks at some instagram
models probably dm's them under some
[ __ ] fake account yeah and then he
goes downstairs he has breakfast or
whatever and then he farts i mean lebron
james just farts he takes a nap
he talks to his kids you know so what
you want what these what people who look
at oh i want to be successful i want to
be celebrity i want to be this
what you really want is you're they're
all everybody's average you can't
you can't escape at being average and
you can't escape suffering
so i think as human beings more focus on
how do i deal with being average and
accepted and how do i accept suffering
because from [ __ ] jeff bezos being
the richest man in the world
to the homeless guy who eats his own
[ __ ] they're both suffering it's just
different forms of suffering
happen for different reasons but you
can't escape either one of them and
there's even bezos
he's got all the money in the world but
many parts of his day are just very
average
so it's just like i don't know what
people want this illusion
that's why i'm kind of happy the
kardashian show even though i know it's
already
ripple effects and all that and it's not
like it just goes away but i'm kind of
happy it's had its time and now it's
moving on
because it's a little bit like
celebrating these extremes of
you got to have this and the big ass and
the big tits and this and that
it's really like it [ __ ] with the our
psyche so much because
the truth is we're all mostly average
and we're all going to suffer and you
can't escape either one of those and the
people that do
i think they go to an extreme either
become donald trump or you become
[ __ ] sean king and either way either
i'm going to be noticed because i'm a
victim
or maybe notice because i want to be
president of the united states but it's
all just trying to escape the fact
that you're [ __ ] average and you're
going to stop it all sounds familiar so
you would think like because when you
know sean king everybody of course knows
he's white even though he keeps saying
he's black it's like we all know and the
truth will come out eventually
just like rachel dolezal who that was
like the big news and like how could
somebody do that how could someone
pretend that they were black when they
were really white and then you see this
has been happening throughout history so
we found a case
all the way from the late 1800s where
he's doing it and you would have to
think it's been happening for hundreds
and hundreds of years before that
and it's probably a lot of people who've
done it who we've never heard of
he got away with it his whole life right
so he didn't do this until like that
this was like the last 13 years of his
life of course he didn't predict it
to be the last 13. but in those 13 years
he lived a double life
as james taught right uh a man named
clarence
do we think james todd is a good black
name is it a cute black game or bruce
blackman i think it's a good one i mean
i
i was saying i mean if you're going to
go hard you got you go like donnell
rawlings always told me
go hard and go home he should go harder
go home i think he should have went
blacker and called himself donnell
rawlings no no wrongs yeah
if i if i literally if i was to get this
if i had to do a black name
i would probably go with a classic one
all new york jets
player i would go with the brick short
to stefano that's what i would say i'm
the brick short to stefano just to get
back to sean king for a second no matter
which way you slice it even if he had
some really light-skinned black it's a
real improbable story
that his mom told him at nine years old
because the official story is his mom
you're nine years old
sean king we're talking about the
present day sean king the civil the the
activist can't they do his ancestry.com
now and see
where his roots came from they totally
could but he won't do it of course he
will now he was offered by some conser
some black conservative i think larry
elder offered him
250 thousand dollar to the charity of
your choice if you took it if you didn't
say
that dna test yeah because he [ __ ]
knows he knows that it's gonna come back
uk baby but his story is that uh his mom
had an affair behind his dad's
back sure and and that's he was this kid
of that
and his mom told him at nine years old
you're right that that's your real dad
and is his mother conveniently dead
right now no his mom's still like what
does his mom say about that
she has i don't know but i don't know if
she's alive i don't need a zucchini
slice
yeah his brother died but uh uh
tragically rest in peace
brother data like leukemia or some
candidates oh sorry yeah but i just want
it it's probably hard because he was
dealing with a lot of [ __ ] stress
trying to keep his brother's dirty
little secret
so i think you killed your brother sean
king you piece of [ __ ] why did you jump
my mom would tell a nine-year-old kid by
the way no
your real dad your real dad is some dude
i banged behind his back
no [ __ ] [ __ ] this looks like my
friend mark herstein who i grew up with
who was a french jewish no look he looks
like he could be puerto rican
for sure he looks like you'd be prayed
or mostly the haircut and the stack it's
the most have a stash like that too when
i was
when i was trying to look puerto rican
yeah so black so this is so when i grew
up it was very cool hip-hop culture was
very cool
so clarence king sean king it's
interesting that both their last names
are king i really
genuinely my heart believe sean king
knew about clarence's king's story
and got inspired by it and even though
it you say its birth certificate i just
don't believe anything comes out of this
[ __ ] kid's mouth
so i think sean king co-opted clarence
king's story and it's just the new king
so that's just what it is and i believe
much like clarence king
told his wife his black wife you know
who
she knew him as james todd on his actual
death bed in 1901 while he was dying of
tuberculosis he said by the way
i'm not black i'm a white guy i'm a
way and i've left you a fortune i think
sean king on his deathbed
will tell whoever his wife is at the
time
that hey by the way i've been white this
whole time
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.com where things get
really wild